Tron
I shall open
flighty so high level fame the father
assalamu alaykum wa rahmatullah wa
medicare to brothers and sisters welcome
to reality 8 on this part we're going to
show can male and females just be first
can they Musa yeah I don't think so so
we're gonna see obviously I'm joking
guys even though you thought you know
soap you get crazy so so yeah we
actually knows about pure matrimony the
most solid website that's been you know
smoking my mini chefs and scholars out
there who recommend it so this channel
do check it out the most allowed me to
find a partner check the links below so
let's go straight into and see what the
females have to say be right back you
believe male and females can only be
friends yes of course
okay have you ever had male friends yes
has any of them been attracted to you I
wanted to be more different some but not
all do you think male and females can
only be friends nothing more I don't
think so I don't know I think it's an
experience and I met a lot of boys and I
wanted to be friends but I just can't
oh yes of course good yeah did you ever
have a friend that was just friend but
he liked you
yes it's happen okay but does that mean
they can still be friends it's difficult
because if there is one person that like
the other one it can be confusing after
can they just be friends nothing more
yeah
have you had ever had a experience where
you saw a guy as a friend but he wanted
to be more than friends if you've been
through that doesn't that show like they
can't really be friends okay do you
believe male and females can only be
friends
yes yeah
yeah okay what because if a girl want a
girl can be friends like on a guy and a
girl do you believe male and females can
only be friends nothing more why not
because once they start hanging out they
create a bond can male if it was me yeah
do you think male and females can only
be friends only be friends well they
they can be yeah yeah yeah just friends
yes let's both okay yeah yeah
Golu two male friends if there's no
attraction there then is what they get
attracted yeah yeah what about you
so moosa' tell me we think about what
just happened but we saw what the
females are saying there is clearly said
you know even with some said no they
can't be fast but most of all I yeah
it's not a wrong that can be friends I
think we should see what the men say
yeah that's a good idea let's go see
what the male say no females do you
think so maybe we've got it wrong
let's see what he doesn't want to say do
you think me or the females can only be
friends nothing wrong
so no naturally chuckles no no I believe
there's always a no so it was a no carry
on it's always inside there's always
feelings there that will make it more
than friendship okay so have you ever
gone through that experience no are you
sure I'm joking to have yes if that's
the case then how could male a female
just be friends because you've got
friends while you're saying if I had the
chance I'll go out with us well for me
I've got self-control still so for me
you know you do for a chat
yeah but um I just if she's my friend
she's my friend you know I mean okay
have you ever had a feeling towards a
friend that's been over that like as
feelings as your friends or friends oh
yeah or like
yet you ever have
hello Russell
yeah
yeah so okay if she all right she saw
you just as a friend yeah yeah
but obviously you have this been has
every movie you said okay if I had the
chance guys it happens you have me think
about it
get up
definite dude you don't recorded read I
can see how you can get
is the condition if the gun is closed it
is not hard yet if she's okay do you
believe male and females can only be
friends yeah have you ever had four
female friends have you ever been
attracted to them cause yeah does that
mean can they be friends Oh cause you're
saying you had female friends but use
attracted to them do you believe male
and females can only be friends can only
be friends nothing loss they can be
friends yeah cool so can so have you
ever had female friends I've never been
attracted to them yeah so can they only
be friends do you believe male and
females can only be friends
absolutely yes okay have you ever had
female friends yes little bit of effort
to them of course can they still he read
the male or female just be friend have
you ever had a female friend that you
was attracted to yes does that mean can
they be friends now robbers and sisters
we see what the females have to say now
the male's clearly contradict for the
females it's a completely completely so
they lie you know what no you want me
even that guy remember that guy would
that go what is that if I said if you
had the chance to go out with her is
that hell yeah of course I've got with
him so you know what this shows their
shows that there's a conflict of
interest here exactly and that's why
that girl walked off she's a better
company what he said I think we should
go into the scientific studies and see
what study she sees on men and women can
just be friends assuming that they're
both heterosexual in this case appears
to be not true this is fascinating
they did a study where they brought in
eighty eight pairs of undergraduate
opposite sex friends into a science lab
and they followed standard protocol as
far as anonymity confidentiality
etcetera but also got people to agree
verbally and in front of each other that
they weren't going to discuss the study
they were going to talk about what they
said to the researchers amongst
themselves after leaving the testing
facility what they tested was presumably
you were just friends and they separated
the the optimum that the man the woman
they said okay
tell me do you have any how
practive do you find your friend to be
how attractive do you think your friend
finds you to be how interested in
pursuing a relationship with your friend
are you okay what do you think they
found you you tell me okay the results
show that there is a huge gender
difference the women did not find on the
whole the men to be particularly
attractive and had absolutely no inkling
that they would ever have a romantic
relationship with the men however the
men number one found the women
attractive number two had a much higher
estimation of how attractive the women
found them to be and also indicated yeah
I would actually be into having a
romantic relationship uh with this woman
so the results really seem to indicate
that men have the harder time being just
friends whereas for women it really
appears to be much more straightforward
to be just right so most of unis just
quickly die summers that summarize it
for us but an Islamic perspective but
also seen the studies what the people
feel obviously what does the pronounce
them to say about as much of course so
obviously living in our normal
day-to-day lives if we think about it
from a woman's perspective yeah and even
from a man's perspective you know
without adding any sense of man in
history let's say I'm just a normal
person I've got an onslaught of
inclination I'm just a normal guy with
living my life I would think why can't I
be friends with a female I mean what's
wrong with it you know yeah like what's
the issue here and this is exactly the
kind of the kind of mindset the females
have on this yeah or strong with it
where's the harm
there is no issue because they have no
sense of inclination towards the man
like that if they see him as a friend
he's a friend and that's it that's why
we have this whole time of being friends
on yeah it's when a female doesn't want
to be more than just a friend so she
just wants to stay with you you know you
stay there so that's true it's actually
the friendzone because when we think
about a friend oh you never think a girl
ends up in the friendzone we always has
perceptual is always there ya go and
this the reason for that is because the
woman always has this perception but the
guy you see the guy has a gender
a lot of the time so I mean if you were
to ask any of the people that you're
friends with if you're a go obviously
don't literally do it because it could
cause Fidan hunter but yeah didn't you
go out to be like yo you know would you
ever go out with me probably say yeah
that's probably the main reason why he's
following you around the reason why he
asks you the questions of all of the
people in the world he could ask now the
reason why he approaches you is because
he has this sense of attraction in and
in no way am I saying all men's are all
men of pervs all of your mate suburbs
all of your mates have these agendas in
their heads that they just want to get
you you know into their room and into
you know their bed or something like
that no it's nothing like that I'm not
saying that but one thing is that in the
quran allah subhanaw taala specifically
mentions that pro of Shaitaan is DYFS
but for the man the claw of the woman is
our Deen strong now I'm not comparing
the Shaitaan to him and of course no of
course not you know yeah some of our
greatest examples are women you'll marry
my salaam osseous ala moana later so we
have these examples of women but the
reason why a Lost Planet Allah says in
the Quran is because of the kind of
effect women have on us it's the kind of
effect we are created it's the way that
we have every eight I was one of those
people yes that his woman yes and the
Prophet SAW Allah Allah instead of say
the same thing exactly and now how does
Islam approach this it's very very
interesting you see we can get attracted
to a friend to a female friend let's say
we can get attracted to her and we want
to make it more yeah but Islam
completely stops it from going any rain
area by what by having this sense of
brotherhood and sisterhood in Islam you
see what we are being told basically is
that look you would never think about
your sister in the way that you're
thinking about this next girl you'd
never up your sister in the way you're
eyeing up this next girl you would never
go up to your sister and try and you
know you know get on her good side the
way that you're trying to do it to this
girl so treat her like your sister this
is why in Islam
any other Muslim female is our sister
and we should treat her as our sister if
she needs any sort of help we should
help her in accordance to Islam of
course and this is the kind of mindset
that allah subhanaw taala is trying to
put in us you see with all of this fit
not going on weaning it's so important
that we have this mindset that we look
at other females as our sisters even in
humanity our sisters yeah and you know
what kind of Fitness subs bro yeah you
won't I up another female you won't
men won't go around doing bad things
like watching porn because would you
ever watch a video for example you come
on yes sister gave me no way so if you
have this mindset it stops you from
going anywhere near zina anywhere near
free mixing anyway you know it's very
valuable because you're like always you
to the mattresses and also analysis in
the front that you should not even body
as you know so when we say are they just
friends you're opening that door I was
not saying don't even go there
by agency now he's just my friend and
you know what the proof is that you're
opening that door yeah
what is he thinking exactly and that's
why this is this is a project only one
weapon but the reviving reality shows
and I want you to being walked as well
it's basically about we hear about
sisters when they start practicing or
whatever they have these guys who spread
rumors about them yeah why because they
try to be go out with them as you can
see the guy said look well say okay so
so as you know the guys go around spread
rumors you say you know what I did this
with an that was widest that a cure
because when the guy ends up in the
friend zone
some of them taking ideas do you know
what it's okay what does some of them do
they say now no he hurts them you want
to say like that that's what we do not
go around and say you know what I did
this to Sarah
what did this to Lena or I did this to
whatever her name is you see I'm trying
to see so they go rather start spreading
rumors and these rumors and carry on and
I think this is how certain may not you
know unfortunately
kind of heard about these kind stuff so
that's why you get these problems you go
out there and basically say you know
what I've done this without that word
because why please so affected by an
eminent friendzone
so that's why we need to understand and
look when Alice Motel we we go back to
our sooner we've seen what the people's
opinions up we've seen how certain
citizen here they can be friends but
brother some guys they know and when
they can't be friends scientific studies
show that they can't you know it doesn't
happen now when it comes to Iran and
sooner that's what we rely on Co science
changes people's opinions change on
Quran as soon as has not changed so
that's what we need to understand
brothers and sisters and look don't fold
that you might you have to see you know
what he's just a friend but believe me
when you're alone you don't know what's
going through his head so what we're
just trying to say is look don't even go
there
you know because you might think he's
just a friend he he doesn't seem like
that is learning and planning and as I
said most both guys are back in days
back oh oh no guys
it'll approaches Angela be that look
crappy number no no no a boyfriend you
know what you say we can't just be
friends because he knows once he gets
there he can work his way up by doing it
what is true though in it you know Ricky
so that's what we need to be careful
here because I didn't awesome that you
know I don't I mean that's pretty much
it you know specifically for the sisters
this should be a sign for you to be
careful
yeah you know a lot of sisters have this
mindset where Oh
for example they might see what we're
saying is extreme like we're saying what
the hell of a little before what we're
calling me friends yeah you have to
understand something you're a female
you'll never be a man yeah
you'll never have the sort of feelings
that we have and if we're telling you
straight that will be difficult
yeah for you to be a friend with a gun
who's actually attracted to you yeah
that's it
yeah know me yeah so what you said was
right now what what what makes what is
really sad is this year is if we came
just with a karana sooner yet a lot of
brothers and sisters and certain people
out there who know about it sound
all these kind of stuff but when we come
with the male perspective the female
perspective and what the scientific
studies showing you know we live in an
age of science in global took it yeah
that's right it's what science showed by
flicking with a pram sooner you brackish
extreme so do you see that it's really
studying it understand when Alice want
to order something for you you notice
for the best you know so that's what we
need to understand the importance of
that brother Faisal mashallah as you can
see his hand she's took on my arm out a
key do you think male and females can
just be friends
nothing more no never they can't be in
it tell them please tell them because we
showed them the male perspective the
female perspective the studies the
piranhas for now but they still not
listening aki
bismillah alhamdulillah - Salam I never
let my bad I'm talking from 30 years of
experience of little bit older than news
lot it doesn't really work I mean if you
think back to school you know year 1112
onwards Sixth Form College University
the way things happen between the
opposite sexes it's never just about
friendship never unless the guy's gay or
there's some problem that's that's what
the study shows was Lonnie sheet look it
can't you know some people say you know
what caranas and but look this studies
not show that it can't happen I mean
obviously the best guidance is the
guidance of the prophet salallahu alaihe
wasalam
the you know the Quran that he revealed
allah sunnatullah revealed to us if we
stick to that we will find that men and
women shouldn't really be friends Allah
has given us the solution you know the
Prophet SAW said we should marry young
parents should advise their children and
try and allow the children to marry as
young as possible and make it easy for
them and not be obstacles and barriers
in their path to lead them to sin you
know they should try and and I'm
speaking as a father as well you know
what it's good because look like I said
yeah like I like it like that
like I like we go in a sermon like I
said look no prom take a call we shall
show you this female's perspective males
perceptive the studies Quran and Sunnah
and we've got an experienced person who
is married and he's telling you what
else do you need was it
Oh Salaam Baalak what I meant to label
better care to brothers and sisters
welcome back now as you know slogan
unity sunshine father and today as you
can see I'm dressed as a the couch guys
now see what the females are what to say
we'll see I'm a D think oh they fit in
what do you think male and females can
just be friends
I'll give you put the specs not me of
course not the sex scene he's gonna be
the vlog mess I seen can a crackhead be
friends with a crack dealer for the
combo sorry for the Martell tickety toad
Angela
but I shall find
hi Eddie so high leveled me